welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and Hulk's son scar has now been
introduced to the MCU the reason Hulk
left to the planet cigar in earlier
episodes of She-Hulk k-e-v-i-n telling
She-Hulk a big [ __ ] off to her desired
ending he said this is my show I will
force in whatever Universe built-in
cameos I want now we begin to speculate
on star and explain who he is earlier
this season but now that he's here on
screen young actor Will dusner's face
via vexed on that body looking super
guilty for crashing Dom toretto's
potluck there's actually a lot that we
can learn from these few seconds
including what's going on with that do
and the Studio's soft confirmation of a
Hulk movie and this video is sponsored
by rain shadow Legends we'll give you
some more info on them in a moment now
in episode one the car wreck that leads
to Jen acquiring Bruce's blood was
caused by that sakharan couriercraft
which Bruce later appears on in episode
2 as he blasts off into space the robot
AI behind Marvel Studios creative
decisions Kevin confirms to Jen the plan
for that plot thread and Bruce who
picked down from literal outer space to
save the day in my story
but Bruce is supposed to return to
explain what he was doing we don't need
to hear any of that but we were going to
introduced save it for the movie
recalculating yeah notice how Kevin says
recalculating not simply an agreement to
change the ending as Jen requested but
other like a voice navigation in your
car find a new path to the same desired
destination so moments later Jen asks
about the future of the Hulk franchise I
do have some thoughts about the
direction of season two you will not be
able to access the kedin again what that
error on our platform has been fixed and
Kevin goes on to say see you on the big
screen
really no ah whatever Kevin so
recalculating could refer to find a
different way to introduce Scar and or
recalculate the algorithmic plan for how
much Jen knows about reality past that
fourth wall to keep her in the blind on
whether or not she's gonna get a movie
also notice how I snuck in an Andor
Easter egg into that sentence please
watch that show it's so good now no
doubt you've heard about rage Shadow
legends from us before the new rockstars
crew can't get enough of it raid is a
console size gaming experience it fits
in your pocket but this game is huge
there are over 600 Champions blessed
with unique skills to choose from and
millions of combinations to battle with
and now raid is released a super powered
legendary version of everybody's
favorite Champion Dash Knight well kinda
here's death knight himself to explain
what's going on Howdy Skeleton Crew the
death knight Hunt is here and I know
what you're thinking it's an event to
celebrate me right wrong it's an event
for a new death knight Ultimate Death
Knight cause what even is life right but
if you log in and play seven times
between now and October 27th Ultimate
Death Knight is yours for free yeah I'm
as mad as you are and if you want your
promo code DK Rises you get enough free
items to instantly upgrade Ultimate
Death Knight to level 50 5 Star
Ascension which is just Insanity really
thanks OG death knight also sorry OG
that night anyone can get a brand new
Ultimate Death Knight for free just by
logging in all you got to do is log in
and play raid for seven days between now
and October 27th and you'll add Ultimate
Death Knight to your collection easy
he's perfect for Reed's brutal new
dungeon the iron twins Fortress if
you're good enough to take down the iron
twins you'll see a huge payoff being
able to awaken your Champions Awakening
your Champions lets you choose a
powerful blessing that can transform how
they perform in battle there seriously
never been a better time to get started
but there's more you can also use the DK
Rises promo code for a bunch of free
items to instantly level up your new
strongest Champion all the way to level
50 5 Star Ascension and if you haven't
started playing radio yet click my link
in the description or scan my QR code
here on the screen and you'll get unique
bonuses worth thirty dollars that means
a free epic Champion Burgess 200 000
silver one energy refill and one XP
boost and one ancient Shard so you can
summon awesome Champions as soon as you
get in game you can get all these
goodies just by going to the treasure
box right here but these bonuses will
only be available for the next 30 days
and only for new players so go download
raid right now so despite Jen's
supposedly persuading Kevin to give her
control over her own ending Kevin
totally ignores her ultimately and
forces Bruce and Scar into the ending of
the season I know I've been away it's a
car for a while I have someone here that
I'd like you all to meet
this is my son scar
wow you're a family oh
son is played by your will dusner with
specific tattoos on his body but an
interesting haircut that looks nothing
like his hair in the comics really to
understand where scar comes from here it
helps to understand his history in the
comics scar was introduced in the 2007
World War Hulk storyline and further
explored in the 2009 scar son of Hulk
Ark basically when Hulk was banished
from Earth by the Illuminati Hulk lands
on the planet's Dakar it becomes a
warrior hero which was partially adapted
for the second act of Thor Ragnarok but
in the comics Hulk Wars against the
leader of Sakari the Red King who sends
Kiera the old strong to kill Hulk but
Hulk and Kiera fall in love they take
charge of the planet and turn it into
Utopia that is until kyera tragically
dies an explosion from the ship that
Hulk used to get to sakar and Hulk
blames the Illuminati for planting that
bomb even though it wasn't them this is
what fills them with rage and takes him
back to Earth to beat the crap out of
the Illuminati and the Avengers this is
the world war Hulk storyline and why
it's so awesome but meanwhile back on
sakar when kyera died she actually
released a cocoon that fell into a lava
lake and spawned scar an offspring of
Hulk who was born looking like a human
boy and ages rapidly scar Target's
tattoos burned into his skin by the
shadow people and falls under the
mentorship of old Sam scar gains What's
called the old Power a kind of
omnipotence developed by the shadow
priest of sakhar technically an
artificial form of the power Cosmic a
Godly cosmic energy wielded by Galactus
gained from his numerous consumptions of
planets and an omnipotence shared by his
Herald the Silver Surfer basically
Galactus is what he eats and it makes
him sad so her server actually comes to
scar to warn him about Galactus and to
encourage scar to use his old Power to
evacuate the planet of sakhar but scar
flips out and destroys the planet
instead so Silver Surfer has to take
Scar's old Power and sticks on him an
obedience disc then in the comics scar
gets exiled to Earth where he battles
with She-Hulk in the Fantastic Four but
when we look at this scar based on his
facial expression and his demeanor alone
this is a kid who's gotten some true
rubble and he was sent home with Daddy
for the summer as punishment he wasn't
properly socialized since the car so the
Grand Master must have called Bruce up
and said come get your boy he's about to
become a world breaker and Bruce fresh
off a few Beach training sessions with
his fuzzball cousin knows nothing's more
important than family emphasis added
because the Fast and Furious family
dinner Vibes are not an accident so
knowing what we know from the comics
what did the MCU scar do on zakar why is
he sad why is he back on earth now and
where will we see him next also who is
this daddy and what does he do scar does
not say anything here but we can pull
three things about his appearance his
facial expression his tattoos and his
haircut I swear I'm not focusing on the
cut just be mean but Mt did wisely point
out on inside marble that it is a common
practice on sakar among Gladiators in
the grand Masters Arena to be forced
into a humiliating haircut by sakara's
official Barber played by Stan Lee in
the 2017 Ragnarok film for Thor it
actually worked out to his benefit with
the best cut I think Chris Hemsworth has
ever had in the MCU more of the high and
tight please leave those luscious logs
for the Lookers in Minnesota's hockey
league peroxide Jesus but for scar
there's a good chance this half moon
hairline was the result of him fidgeting
too much with Stan Lee this gets a
fighter one of the grand Masters
Gladiators I suspect a line of that by
the way also included recent MCU
newcomer men thing but like Creed Johnny
to live up to his father's Legacy there
is a tremendous pressure on the son of a
champ and especially when they have no
visible Father Figure in their lives it
leads to a pretty sharp temper his
tattoos might also mean scar has a
history with the shadow people in the
shadow priests if so that would mean
he's got a bit of that old Power
omniscience kicking around in those
veins so why is scar Chad in the
alternate version of this video's
thumbnail that you would have made fun
of us for well maybe the reason this kid
had to leave sakar is that Galactus was
on his way and this scar knows that
Earth is the next Target this scar is
scarred and scarred like Tony Stark and
Thanos in I guess ajac and Cersei but
who gives a [ __ ] about them scar is
cursed with knowledge of an apocalyptic
future this would position scar as an
interesting figure not just for a future
Hulk title or a Young Avengers title but
something already on the calendar
Fantastic Four where do you think we'll
see scar next and do you think he'll get
along with Thor's Daughter love who
would win in that fight follow me on
Tick Tock Instagram and Twitter follow
new rockstars And subscribe to new
rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
foreign
[Music]